LONGEST WINNING STREAK AT EIGHT
GAMES.
WITH THE
SEASON.
GAVE UP FIVE BUT PICKED UP WIN
IN WILD ONE SUD
TO PASS TO RUST, COULDN'T
CONNECT.S TRIES TO GO
, CROSBY
GUENTZEL, AND BACK IN FRN CHANC
ENDS TO START THIS HOCKE REPORT
BLUES TO START THE SECOND
PERIOD, AND BRAYDEN SCHENN
SCORES
LOOKED LIKE PITTSBURGH PENGUGUT
Y
TARASENKO, FROM THAT POINT.
RODRIGUES TO THE FRONT, ALL
ALONE WAS S  OF
INJURY.
D VISION, AND
MAYBE IT'S THEO THE FAR
SIDE.
LETANG, TOUCH PASS FORG PASS, ,
ROW, IT'S ONE-GOALT
THE STOP AND ST. LOUIS, SEVENTH.
SPECEC MOST OF THE
SECOND PERIOD.
>> Brendan: BACK ON THE ICE NOW.
THAT HIT SIMON IN THE BACK,  BL.
WORKING HARD IN THBACKHAND BEHI
PASS OUTSIDE OF THOKS LIKE HE'S
OUTSIDE THE PAINT.
WHETHER IT'S PANTS'M THINKING C
GOOD HOCKEY GOAL.
>> Referee: AT REVIE
AND PITTSBURGH PENGUINS' POWER
PLAY GOING TO WORK, TRYING TO
TAKE LEAD FIRST TIME, RODRIGUES
SCORES AHEAD.
EVER DEALING WITH
ASTON-REESE, CENTERING FEED,
GIVEN AWAY AND GOAL!
ICE, RIGHT ON THE TAPE TO
BLUEGER, GET